Ron DeSantis has put himself in somewhat
of a pickle a conundrum a difficult
situation and I want to talk about that
now uh he because he got prominent being
the culture War guy the woke woke woke
CRT guy Auntie woke woke I should say
CRT guy
um
Florida is where woke goes to die you
know who I'm talking about that Rhonda
said this he became a big conversation
item for running for president possibly
challenging uh Trump in the 2024
presidential primary and he leaned into
and he's made clear with all of his
actions his tour and all that that it's
something he's planning on doing
but now it's seeming like not a great
idea and I want to show you before we
discuss further Sarah Longwell on MSNBC
talking about how he kind of now is
forced to go ahead and just run
but
and we'll discuss this more a second
it's not really a it's not a good time
for him to run but he kind of has to
which is fascinating what do you think
the chances are does Santa decides not
to run
oh I don't think he can decide at this
point not to run he's effectively
already in the race this really uh is
his moment yes he's a young guy but if
he you know he's positioned himself
really as a fighter and if he bows out
of this particular fight he will never
uh get that reputation back and the fact
is right now there is a big chunk of the
party you know I do focus groups every
week uh with Trump voters there's a big
chunk of the party that is DeSantis
curious and that wants to move on from
Donald Trump but Ron DeSantis is going
to have to figure out you know who he's
playing to in this primary he's sort of
decided for some reason that he's trying
to out Trump trump with the base
um and I think that's a mistake I think
he should be trying to consolidate
um these sort of move on from Trump
voters and trying to to Really you know
build relationships with them and build
a broad enough Coalition uh that he can
start getting these numbers back and he
can't do this thing where he decides to
be sort of a support player in the drama
around Donald Trump's indictment uh
where he's now out there defending Trump
he's gonna have to figure out a
different strategy than that if he wants
to be effective
yes so what makes it hard for him to not
run now is number one is she noted if
he's branding himself as his fighter and
uh all of that but then he gets scared
Away by Trump and it was obviously it
was obvious he was gonna run but then he
decides not to and it's clear why that
doesn't look great but more importantly
he's already taking the political
attacks and the damage from Trump
because Trump identifies him as a
challenger and an enemy and so he's
getting the negatives of being attacked
by Trump but not the possible benefit of
being successful in a primary but then
if he does end up running now that the
indictment has happened and as she was
talking about
he is
being a supportive character in his
story and his indictment and all of that
there's no way a kind of I'm sort of the
Trump without baggage and I can out
Trump on vaccines maybe I could be more
anti-vaxx than him and more anti-woke
than him
but all some supportive of his dishonest
narratives and all these just different
areas including the indictment
um that's not going to work when Trump's
one of the candidates being a trump 2.0
when Trump's one of the candidates and
they can just pick the original
is definitely not a successful
strategy now would it work for anyone to
try to consolidate the non-trump vote I
don't know is there enough anti-trump
vote within the Republican party to even
make that possible or enough anti-plus
people who like Trump but want to move
on from him because a younger generation
or someone without baggage
I don't think so I think the majority of
the GOP is still on Trump's side but
that probably would be a better strategy
than just hey I'm like him but a little
better a little younger and
a little less baggage
um and
the attacks keep coming from Trump here
on true social Rhonda santis is a young
man who is not doing well against me in
the polls that is true uh Sans is doing
much worse these days to put it mildly I
believe that if he decides to run for
president which will only hurt and
somewhat divide the Republican Party he
will lose the cherished and massive
macro vote and never be able to
successfully run for office again if he
remains Governor which is what Florida
voters assumed it would be a whole
different story just saying but who
knows he has such different moods on
true socialist either ah Rado Sanchez is
the worst and maybe he was a groomer
look at this photo or just a thought you
know maybe he shouldn't run but you do
you
but the uh Trump versus DeSantis Saga is
one I've been definitely enjoying
watching and we will continue to watch
it good habits have to be sustainable
something you'll actually stick to I
start my mornings with a scoop of ag1 by
our sponsor athletic greens because it's
just so simple one scoop of ag-1 gives
me the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins and minerals from whole
food sources half of Americans are
deficient in vitamin A C and magnesium
taking that scoop of ag-1 makes sure
that I'm getting the nutrients I want
without fumbling with different capsules
and dosages and all of these things ag1
is also way more cost effective than
buying all of those different vitamins I
drink ag1 straight with water because I
like the taste but you could put it in a
smoothie a juice a protein shake I would
not promote bogus supplements making
crazy claims there's no crazy claims
here ag1 is just a simple product it
does what it says it does it helps me
get what I want to get every day and
when you go to athleticgreens.com Pacman
you will get a free year supply of
vitamin D plus five free travel packs of
ag1 I've talked about vitamin D before
the link is down below